hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the ways
that we try to explain the nature and
the acquisition of virtue to people when
they're first studying virtue ethics is
by comparing the the virtues or likening
the virtues to the kind of knowledge
that we develop through skills or our
crafts or arms what Aristotle and Greece
called
Technic which is a word by the way that
we get technology from ultimately but in
this case means some sort of discipline
or skill that a person has developed so
what would be examples of those
well rhetoric itself is is an example
because Arizona will title his book the
rhetoric the technique Roderick
but there's a lot of other things as
well Madison was understood to be the
tech name as well as sometimes called an
epistemology disciplinary knowledge all
the different handiworks
weaving pottery you know metalworking
all of those are tec-9 really anything
that is a productive act in so being a
musician for example is a technique and
why does one is Aristotle want to
compare and contrast virtues with with
craps well because in a certain way of
virtue it is a type of knowledge it's
analogous to a craft and then it allows
us to carry out performances
consistently so when we were thrown into
situations that are not you know the
same as other situations that we've seen
so we're a little bit unprepared for
them they the particulars are different
Aristotle would say we can carry out
what an education we call transfer of
knowledge right so if I understand what
it means to be generous in this context
I can then if I really have virtue
probably transfer that over here to this
context I might get mixed up about some
of the particulars but I can get
straightened out about them and then I
can see how to make that work and if
it's similar with the crafts that we
have if you really are a good carpenter
it's not just doing the same thing over
and over and over again you can adapt to
new situations and see you know looking
through them how do we do this great
example of this my uncle master
craftsman now in two different fields he
was a drywaller
since high school and at first drywall
is very rough stuff and hanging it
there's not an awful lot of art involved
although there's some because I mean
just go into the house where somebody's
done bad drywall and you can see the
effects of it right it's one of those
sort of things where the less you can
notice it the better it is and that's
not just due to the hanger it's also due
to the mutter and and other things
however as his career progressed because
he was an intelligent guy and interested
in what he was doing and picking up
things along the way from older people
there is sort of apprenticeship type of
type of
activity he learned how to do amazing
stuff with drywall where he could you
know wet it and then bend it the right
way and he could walk into a place and
say we're gonna make this many sheets
for this and I'm gonna have to cut it
this way for that weird little bed up
there
that is a prime example of craft
knowledge just as much as a musician who
has to figure out how to adapt a
Prokofiev piece to a different ensemble
of instruments and it's something very
admirable
now the virtues are like that in many
respects they provide us with the
ability to produce consistent
performance not so much in in terms of
production but now in terms of our
actions and our emotions so there are
analogies between the virtues and the
tec-9 that's the plural for tech name
the crafts one of these is that you're
only a real craft person if you actually
possess the knowledge of the correct if
you're just doing things by going on the
internet and watching a few videos and
then seeing kind of do it you're not
anything they could be part of your
training
but you're not yet a craftsperson if in
music you know you're still using the
tablature you kind of really learn the
song yet at that point having and so on
so - you could only really say that
somebody has the knowledge that goes
with a craft if they really do in fact
exhibit that if they're going by
somebody else's guidance they're not yet
at that point we can say the same thing
about virtue can't wait if you always
have to be told what the right thing to
do is you are not yet virtuous you may
in fact be doing virtuous actions if you
have a question about the distinction
between doing virtuous actions and being
virtuous go and take a look at the
about virgin as a norm for moral
evaluation there is a very important
difference there a kid can be a good kid
because there still within the framework
of punishment and reward and they do the
right thing but they're not yet virtuous
they are only able to do that when
they're truly on their own and can
actuate that knowledge another very very
important likening between crafts people
and those who are virtuous is this
entire notion of the mean Aristotle
thinks that it's not just in moral
issues but also in the craft that we're
trying to find the mean or the middle
position because that is what is best he
gives the example of works of art where
you can tell that they're complete this
is a very hard thing to do by the way in
music sculpture writing to figure out
when you've got the right proportions
and you shouldn't add anything more
that's why it when it comes to good
writing much of good editing is actually
trimming things away you know sort of
like a sculptor like carving the marble
away from what it is that they're doing
and so there's there's a connection
there now all that said the virtues are
not crafts and there are some very
important dissimilarities that Aristotle
wants to point out to us one of these
has to do with what we could call the
performance and the agent of performance
the works of art as Aristotle says have
their good condition or their goodness
their ma their their being you know in
in a stable good condition in themselves
so this is why you don't need the
craftsperson
around after you have had it done man in
fact you don't want them are not most of
the time right you don't want to go to
the doctor after you've been healed you
don't want to go to the dentist after
you've had a group can help so maybe for
a checkup
you don't want it then we could go on
and on around with us right that's not
the case for the virtues though
the virtues their their goodness of
being in good condition has to do with
something external the actions or the
emotional responses that are exhibited
but it lies primarily in the person who
is where the virtue exists the person is
the thing that's the same coming the
situation after situation after
situation and so you can say maybe
you're trying to make yourself into a
work of art there people who like to
talk that way
these days but that's not the way
Aristotle season another very important
thing that distinguishes these two main
classes of what we can call habits moral
virtues and craft knowledge is that both
involve knowledge right so the crafts
person does know something it's not the
same thing as knowing a textbook or
knowing you know mathematics but it is
knowing something the virtuous person
also knows something they have certain
principles that they're using to arrive
at good conclusions for practical
reasoning but in order to be virtuous
two other things are needed deliberate
choice prior ASIS which we're going to
talk about in another video meaning you
know a commitment of the person to that
you know what is that they're doing for
the sake that they of the value of it
moral choice with you College also at
Mitchell disposition this is really
central as well
and Aristotle here says that in order to
be a craftsperson you don't actually
have to have all of that with respect to
the product that you're generating you
it's more important that you have the
knowledge whereas revert you the
knowledge itself is in some respects
less important the deliberate deliberate
choice in the habitual disposition
actually mattered more than merely
having the knowledge and he says
something very funny
the other philosophers have said at
different points lately played over a
patinas he talks about people who
don't actually have with a ton of the
knowledge which they they've gotten sort
of from a textbook but they don't
actually use it and they talk about it
rather than making it effective
here we go the mass of mankind instead
of doing virtuous actions what you have
to do in order practice virtue have
recourse to discussing virtue and fancy
they are pursuing philosophy and that
this will make them good people
nobody ethics doesn't make you a good
person practicing ethics will make you a
good person but that's a lot harder that
demands a lot of work time you have to
make choices
usually choices that are tough choices
and you have to work to the point that
it becomes a habitual disposition now
you could say by response that perhaps
some of those things apply to some of
the crafts that there are a lot of
deliberate choices that certain crafts
people have to make and that it is a
habitual disposition eventually for them
but we can still say well it's it's
within a different realm productive
knowledge versus what we can call
practical knowledge knowledge of how we
want to practice how we want to exhibit
things in our actions in our emotions
and how we order goods and respond to
other people